[Music]
I'm the one
all right episode 274 as usual we're
starting right on time 8 30. always and
uh Rob what's up please be respectful
but respect I think since a lot of
things have been starting late this week
I think it was apparently for us to do
the opposite and I was I was gonna say
let's have some glitches let's have the
internet go on let's have the audio
issues all this stuff but let's just
let's just make it work exactly yes
anyways hey it's good to be here with
you guys uh um we got a lot of stuff to
talk about today gang a lot of stuff to
talk about
um obviously there was an announcement
made by this uh Governor a great
Governor State of Florida
he made the uh announcement for running
for office on Twitter spaces broke the
internet 700 000 people live Elon had to
switch from his to David sacks and then
uh the world had a chance to listen to
the scientist's announcement how he went
about doing it we got a bunch of
different stories to go through videos
to look at some things are funny you are
going to crack up the reaction from the
other side the reaction from Biden's
side the reaction from Trump's side
which one of them was just absolutely
Epic and then a video Vinnie did this
week I want to show that was
accidentally I've not been messaged this
many times saying what the hell is going
on with this clip maybe we'll get into
that clip as well in a minute but first
thing I want to do is I want to talk
about how the mainstream media sold it
to their audience on how the scientists
did let's first start off with New York
Times so five takeaways from a rocky
2024 debut New York Times number one
taking risks on Twitter backfired okay
cool the Santa's campaign launch on
Twitter was plagued by technical
difficulty lasting over 25 minutes the
glitches overshadowed his announcement
and disappointed supporters
fine two DeSantis appeals to educated
right Wingers the census resonates more
with college educated Republicans than
with those without college degrees his
Twitter event delved into Idol
ideological and wonky topics discussing
issues like alternative accreditation
accreditation regimes and debanking of
Politically Incorrect business okay cool
number three DeSantis indirectly targets
Trump while the sentence didn't mention
Trump Bynum he aimed to contrast himself
from the former president he criticized
Trump's failure to build a complete
border wall and signaled his intention
to focus on attacking Trump's personal
appointments from his first term okay
four DeSantis positions himself as a
China Hawk DeSantis presented himself as
tough on China focused on countering its
influence
territorial expansion and Military
Ambitions five the centers planned plans
brought use of executive power okay so
these are or he highlighted his ability
to effectively wield power and enact
conservative policies as governor of
Florida boom so this is New York Times
now let's go to wapo again neither one
of these papers are going to be for the
santis wapo four takeaways from DeSantis
launch number one core argument he aimed
to lead a movement and the Republican
Party distinguishing himself from Trump
okay two focus on the cultural War the
sentence aligns with the anti-woke owned
the lips ethos of the GOP three
inauspicious launch the census campaign
launched on Twitter spaces face
technical difficulties chances and
opportunities this enters timing may not
be ideal As Trump has regained his front
runner status maybe they're right with
that one here's another one coming from
the hill five takeaways number one
Twitter's Tech misfire undermines the
Santa Central case same we heard it
before Twitter and uh Trump and Biden
United and gloating we'll talk about
that here in a minute a great night for
the other not Trump candidates
uh Republican contenders positioning
themselves against Trump capitalize on
the sentences Messi launch Nikki Haley
Tim Scott ASA Hutchinson and even Glenn
Junkin gained opportunities to
differentiate themselves from the
centers four the sentence tries to
repair the damage on Fox News and five
the Santa stumble comes at the start of
a marathon so this is all the criticism
and then last one I'll read it in time
I'm going to come to you right after
this wapa talks about 10 things to know
about DeSantis on one is running on
number one anti-lgbt legislation two
Feud with Disney three abortion
restrictions four restricting
African-American studies diversity
programs five expanded gun axes six
anti-immigration measures seven Ukraine
remarks eight election crimes Unit Nine
coronavirus protection and 10 escalating
Feud with Trump now having said that Tom
Vinnie Adam you guys listen to the
Twitter spaces what was your biggest
takeaway was it good was it bad was it
in different well they can talk about
their takeaway from actual DeSantis what
I'll talk about is my takeaway from the
media coverage the media is focusing on
what happened they should be terrified
that it happened it happened on Twitter
spaces uh you take a look at Elon Musk
is is not a loser she's a long time
winner this is first five moves for him
of what's going on this is the
legitimacy of Twitter as a major
broadcast media player you remember you
see a couple launches Rockets fall
things like that happen and all of a
sudden starlink has got 4 100 satellites
in orbit and they actually helped
Ukraine with internet service during a
global global war bet against bet
against uh Elon Musk if you want but the
rest of this shows that there's a
triangle if you're a Conservative
candidate in America you have to beat
your liberal candidate and you have to
beat the media and that is what is
forming here you have to beat two things
the media is not going to be this hard
on uh Biden and so what I saw about the
media was a bunch of obvious things oh
he's going to use executive orders well
you want to go back look at Obama's
record on executive orders it was his
favorite tool you know so how can you
say oh DeSantis is going to use electric
executive orders they all do it when
they can't get it through Congress but I
think that the media's coverage here was
a bit whiny and a bit hopeful that they
could throw some dents at it and don't
bet against Elon Musk how do you think
he did though I I think I think I think
I'm sorry go ahead one sentence for me I
thought it was a real quiet opening it
was a very dour reading for those first
minutes and finally toward the end of it
as he and David sacks got into a bit of
a rhythm and Q a he seemed to humanize
and there was really some things there
that I thought were good but the opening
I thought was dry I don't think it was
inspiring yeah first of all because of
the the glitch I think it gave people
something to talk about like oh my God
everybody here was all tripping out but
I said if it was a SpaceX launch that
moment that thing would have crashed
right when it went up two seconds that
thing would have fell down but in
regards to the speech I think the first
couple minutes they did sound like he
was just reading and reading and reading
but then once the paper was down he's
saying Pat basically everything that
Trump basically has said in the past
correct everything with the anti-woke uh
anti-covet lockdowns everything like
that China you know it's the same thing
as Trump so one has to ask uh themselves
is the D is is he gonna get the same
treatment as the Deep State comes after
him just like they did with Trump you
know I mean like we they're gonna have
to obviously go after him Pat but then
what pissed me off about the media uh
the left this is how you know you're
doing something right for the people and
for the country the racism they have to
come at you with racism uh in regard to
the Twitter space event that Landing
basically said anybody listening was a
Nazi if you were listening that you were
a Nazi Vanity Fair said Ron DeSantis
will formally announce yes and you show
the vanity Fairway hypothetic yeah they
go Ronda Santos will formally announce
his 2024 bid with Elon Musk because
apparently David Duke wasn't available
that's basically saying elon's a racist
which I think is BS and if you think
about it NAACP the chairman they
announced a travel warning like like it
was like terrorism they're like Florida
is actively hostile to minorities and
people should stay away from Florida but
you know the funniest thing is that the
the chairman of the NAACP Leon Russell
gets where he lives Tampa Florida what
kind of hypocrite scumbag are you to be
sitting in Florida say hey don't come
here they're crazy but you live here so
it's hypocrite maybe he doesn't want the
crazies to come here maybe he's kind of
like don't come here let's just get the
you know he kind of wants it he kind of
wants it all to himself strategic yeah
Adam all right well I get I broke down
this into five different sections and I
gave each one a grade just to kind of
make this very simple so Elon Musk
Twitter everything that happened there I
give them a c minus
um clearly it was not their best day
clearly it was not a good look but uh
welcome to the tech World ladies and
gentlemen this is how kind of things
work sometimes but uh the reason they
didn't get an F for it's not some
disaster it's like
the writing's on the wall what's the
next thing that he tweeted out when he
said all presidential candidates are
welcomed here on Twitter how many do you
think are going to take them up on that
offer my guess is a bunch probably not
Biden definitely okay I could see people
on the left I could see RFK doing it I
could see Marian Williams doing it doing
it Gavin Newsom will jump do it I don't
know if I can have a Newsome but I think
he would I certainly think people on the
right I think at some point Trump's
gonna succumb to this uh at the end of
the day all presidential candidates are
most welcome on the platform thank you
Elon
um
as far as the scientist goes I think
this was actually a good thing for him
because if there's one thing that that
DeSantis is is a policy wonk and he
knows his stuff he's very technical and
he knows all his stuff when we met with
him it was very robotic and sort of
systematic and uh politician that's who
he is you know you talked about which I
think is such a good point I actually
don't think it's politicians no I don't
think he's a politician no and I'll come
back okay but I love what you I
if we can give the essence of I think
your message to to DeSantis is that the
Gladiator uh metaphors that when the
people win your freedom and I don't
think he's there yet I think he's gonna
win over smart college educated Rhino
Maga even those types of guys he's not
he hasn't won over Maga or the people
yet so he gets a b
um
Trump trump he gets an a he gave a
response that was clear hilarious people
people say all the time Trump is so
funny Trump is so funny no I think he's
entertaining yeah I think it's like
watching a car wreck sometimes I'm never
laughing out loud yeah this was
legitimately funny and I gotta give him
credit where credit's due his marketing
team puts it together this this whole
thing which I'm sure will play hilarious
a for that we'll play that uh Biden uh a
minus simple he put a message out he
said basically hey click this link it
actually works donate he raised the
millions of dollars boom that's that was
it and then last but not least my fifth
one is the mainstream medium they got a
B minus why because uh they look good on
paper you know it's kind of like the
Lakers in uh 05 they look good on paper
when they played the Pistons but then
they got their ass whooped and I think
that's exactly what's gonna happen here
um is that more and more people more and
more candidates are going to come to
Twitter and not go to mainstream media
so uh those are my grades for the five
major players in this matter
you know like they call the Deep States
the Deep State because they run deep
like you don't think they're gonna
figure out a way they have to stop
they're they're probably going crazy
because this was such a successful thing
once it came on after the glitch because
once you know in the future these
glitches aren't going to happen what
what do you think is it like Pat they're
gonna have to kind of try to stop this
because if you get to you get to hear
this raw nobody is editing nobody's it's
not because journalism is dead if you
ask me it's just it's up to you to find
the truth this is just the truth you're
just hearing the person raw do you know
what I mean you mean they're gonna have
to stop it because what they're worried
they're true because that like we're
getting real-time information that's not
censored it's not biased it's not Fox
it's not CNN it's just you're listening
to the person you're getting it rather
just giving them the platform well and
Elon mentioned that during the Twitter
spaces that this is the future instead
of doing Town squares where a few people
in your town can go and sit down and
talk to the candidate now anybody on the
globe the global Town
Square so I'm thinking yeah they have to
be going crazy right now because they're
like oh but God we're getting you know I
mean Legacy Media all these people now
now this is like raw right in your face
no nobody's biased it's just talking to
the person directly yeah you know right
after the the thing was over with I
posted the following okay my biggest
takeaway from the whole thing I was
listening to it on the plane when we
landed we're in New York we're at the
tarmac I'm about to go to the Yankees
game and I'm listening to this whole
thing and I was able to catch the whole
thing simply thanks to them the
technology having some problems it was
on time I wouldn't have missed the first
20 minutes and here's what I got number
one Twitter needs to move out of a
headquarters in California ASAP ASAP
there is no need
for a company to be in a city or a state
that doesn't like you or support what
you stand for and you're an enemy and
you're down the street from all your
direct competitors that want to see more
problems for you so I don't know if that
issue that took place was anything that
was from the inside that was Tech that
was enemies that was competitors I don't
know all I know is Twitter needs to move
to Florida or Twitter needs to move to
Austin Texas I mean Austin Texas one of
those two obviously Austin makes more
sense because he lives there but imagine
if he actually says I believe so much in
the governor being a president imagine
Elon Musk making this announcement I
believe so much and the governor being
the president of the United States that
we are making an announcement that we're
moving the headquarters of Twitter to
Miami Florida imagine that announcement
to show the kind of support for the
governor something like that by the way
if I was the scientist I would have
negotiated that mayor of the Miami mayor
Suarez would say how can I help
foreign
marketing campaign immediately they
responded and they posted a link I don't
know if you have that that said this
sling War this link works hurry up and
go donate so smart guess what great job
to their marketing team exactly to their
marketing team not to buy not to Kamala
to their marketing team this is exactly
what you're supposed to do let's see how
many likes that got it it had to have a
lot of likes 121 000 likes okay that's
great so people go to 13.8 million I
love it this is the right move as an
enemy as a competitor capitalize off the
mistakes off the opposition three
whether this become successful launch or
not uh for Ron the scientist this is the
future so by the way for me a part of
the uh call I listened to when they were
making an announcement
all I thought about to myself was in
many cases Rob if you can go back to the
other tweet in many cases it was almost
as if musk and sax were selling
Twitter just as much as they were
selling the santis and if I was even to
put a ratio of what that was really all
about I put 60 percent DeSantis I put 40
Twitter the the selling of it was this
is the direction I didn't see it as a
form of an endorsement I saw it as a
form of a we are here word of future
that's kind of how it was sold so kudos
to those guys for what they did by the
way I don't know who came up with the
idea and who sold it to the other person
but whoever that did sell it to the
other person respect you brilliant move
and Pat you wouldn't say though at that
point but because of that move and that
first time and that then they wouldn't
be like voting for The xanthus Elon and
uh they they've made it clear they've
spoken if she speaks sign language yeah
they've given plenty of signs that they
don't want to vote for Trump at least uh
musk has we don't want a president above
70 years old we don't he's made it very
clear Trump has called out to Santa I'm
sorry Elon Musk before yeah okay you
want Elon on your side by the way David
sack what's his role exactly at Twitter
David sacks is probably musk's most
trusted advisor and friend right here
man one of the most David sacks I was
very impressed one of the things I like
about this guy uh and I think he needs
to get more involved he is pretty active
but I think he needs to get even more
active he's calm he's poised he's a
great host on a call like this I'm just
very impressed by him on the way he
handled listen in a situation like that
when shit's hitting the fan people don't
know how to handle themselves you got
millions of people that are watching you
dying to criticize your platform and
it's just cool calm and Collective very
impressive five mainstream media will
have the initial after long term they're
not going to have to laugh they may as
well go buy a plot
there's cemeteries coming soon Rob if
you can pull that up here for people to
see Amen to that DeSantis was reading a
script I kind of think that's boring
submit a dream tell me a story tell me
why America is the greatest country in
the world sell me the dream and the
nightmare the only thing I heard was The
Nightmare you're not gonna win just
selling the nightmare sell me the dream
as well there's an element of selling
the nightmare yes this is a great season
to sell the nightmare but tell me what's
going to happen if you're in there let
me tell you our dreams are going to
become a reality we're going to talk
about the dream language zero dream
language on the call at all seven Trump
needs to schedule his next Twitter live
as soon as possible uh I think it'll be
the biggest one in the history of uh
Twitter I think it'll be five times
bigger than this one I think before they
do Trump's they best do it outside of
the state of uh California they better
do it in a place where the servers and
the state is backing them up a place to
do it out of would be Texas because
Florida is obviously going to favor
DeSantis Texas is going to be a little
bit more moderate between DeSantis and
Trump eight musk was just as big as a
star as DeSantis was I made that point
already nine
he told one joke uh about the
congressman's license plate from
Kentucky and it was actually a decent
joke the reason why I like that is
because this shows you can tell jokes
you can be witty do more of it you only
did it one time in an hour and 15
minutes if you can tell maybe increase
it if I'm talking to the guy I'm gonna
say one joke every 10 minutes okay try
to break the ice or make people laugh or
be witty once every 10 minutes and once
every 10 minutes give maybe once every
15 minutes self-deprecate yourself a
little bit once every 15 minutes that's
a basic rule one joke every 10 15
minutes one self-deprecation thing every
10-15 minutes you sound too perfect 10.
by the way you open to being his uh
comic coach 100 you need some help I
will do in a heartbeat okay there's a
difference when the audio or only format
versions this kind of a it's easier to
lose the audience when you're doing
something where I can't see your face
you got to tell stories storytelling
matters tell a couple stories don't just
comment here's what we're gonna do
here's what we're gonna do now I would
take 20 of all the policies that he has
okay 20 policies and I would have my
team around and I would have five to ten
stories under each one of these policies
to say let me tell you about Marianne
Jones she lives in Tallahassee Florida
when I was meeting Tim you know she was
32 years old single mother with two kids
and here's what took place tell me
stories for me to go there 11. Rob go up
at the end at the end it showed he
showed his Edge which I freaking loved
the fight came out a little bit it was
good it was competitive Americans love a
competitor and then super slow start but
a great strong uh finish uh and last but
not least when I applaud these guys for
doing this this was a big risk to be the
first to do this it's a very very very
risky Elon won last night two nights ago
we would have done it last night I was
out of town Elon Juan DeSantis one
Twitter one uh digital media one
mainstream media got destroyed you know
what they look like and sound like
here's what you look and sound like just
so you know I know you don't know this
it's like that group of arrogant Elite
kids in school that went to the parties
from the rich families and they would
laugh in the way
you sound like a [__] qualified [__]
insecure shitless because if God forbid
mainstream media gets destroyed and you
don't have a teleprompter what the hell
are you gonna do without a teleprompter
what the hell are you gonna do without
those writers in this space there is no
teleprompter you have to be able to
collect and talk give your thoughts
opinions host banter be wrong risk
screwing it up and none of those things
do you guys like most of you there's a
few of you guys that do a great job I
like Tapper I like few the guys out
there that are doing what they're doing
I agree but for the most part mainstream
media you got maybe three five years if
you're lucky 10 years numbers came back
the other day how you know it went from
2016 was 70 percent of people watching
cable to now it's 40 percent okay drop
that massive in seven years what do you
think the drop's gonna be in the next
three to five years because here's how
drop goes drop goes like this
you're here right now you haven't yet
you know how you go up to up to uh or a
Viper or whatever these rides are on
Magic Mountain
you're barely coming down yeah and then
everybody and then boom it goes so
they're here right now it's about to go
and everybody screams everybody screams
yeah except these guys gonna be crying
because they're not as tough as they act
like they are uh yo what's this here oh
shoot I gotta do my sponsor read by the
way what a great sponsor read to do
because we got a lot of people on let's
go and these guys got a good one here so
Dimitri I met this guy he invited me to
go to his event went to his event he
runs a YouTube channel for uh uh for uh
uh what do you call it um
for uh the business they're in uh man I
was about to joke about it talk about
Plumbing because I did the joke on
Plumbing it's not Plumbing you can
listen every 10 minutes self-deprecating
yeah
knock knock
so Mario joke before I give it a
sponsorship Mario sends me a text
message saying Pat we need this video
made for an ad for this guy and all this
other stuff and Mario's about to get on
a flight and I send the video to Mario I
wish I could even show you guys what the
video was if you see this video we
almost need to show this video so I you
know what I'm gonna do this to get these
guys because I like what this guy stands
for okay we're gonna do this a little
longer than usual Mario if you can send
this video I sent you where you lost
your mind on the flight calling Sam and
Karina everybody saying why did you just
get the app wrong yeah you told me what
is this all about I told you guys I give
you specific Direction man if I I wish I
had I was with you if Mario is listening
to it he has to tell oh there it okay
this is the one is this the one
yeah so this is a roofing conference rob
you have to play this it's a roofing
it's a roofing conference this guy
Dimitri is it in that space he's
crushing it he's gotta imagine having a
roofing YouTube channel you got almost
100 000 Subs it's a niche Roofing 100
000 Subs so Mario asks me for this if
you can play this other Florida baseball
with their business models all across
the country uh so this is why I kept
thinking Plumbing at first because I was
the joke yeah I got you rob do you have
it or no
give me one minute it just went to my
computer not my phone so okay I can send
it to your phone as well if you want me
to man this is a little too funny here
and so so how did this meet happen Pat
who who so the they got this guy to meet
you I have to do this I have to show
this show first okay do the spot okay
Rob if you got it he's getting antsy
Mario's on a flight he has to get the
sponsorship okay over to Dimitri's camp
and he's is taking off to go see Barbie
in Arizona yeah and I'm sending him the
wrong video oh my God and he's saying on
purpose he's saying the guy's name is
Dimitri it is a roofing conference 2 000
people are gonna be there yeah okay and
talk about you know the economy the
challenges all the stuff that's taking
place in the marketplace okay and give a
message about how you know we're gonna
help uh address some of these issues Rob
is it coming through or no
just taking a second because it's a
large files
the Twitter server what's the videos but
at least Dimitri's company can fix it
you know what I'm saying see how that
worked Rob how much longer so if you're
doing that I'm just going to go sponsor
because this is taking a little too long
yeah if you want to read the sponsor
anyways listen uh when we first moved to
Texas to Dallas uh within okay you have
it right there go for it if you want to
make a bigger watch this season watch
this so imagine don't play yeah so the
guy's name is Dimitri got it it's
Roofing okay okay and it's in I think
it's in Orlando okay and he gives some
dates the dates he gives me specifically
our February 26th or whatever listen to
the dates okay go go ahead and play this
hey Patrick David here can I wait to see
all of you guys on February 30th at
Joseph desana's underground plumbing
conference I know a lot of you guys
maybe had a rough year some of you guys
are trying to raise money some of you
guys cannot make it through the pipes
whoever you are I look forward to seeing
you at Orlando February 30th uh do not
get registered you still have time I'll
see you guys there oh my God how and
Mario's Mario is calling everybody's
please take it off trying to get this
video the guys who's Joseph vasana it's
not on February 30th what is this
underground plumbing conference oh
anyway so that's what I thought about
Plumbing let me go back to the
sponsorship so we moved to Dallas first
five days we make the mistake
of leaving our cars outside we have no
clue what happens in Dallas and so I got
my 750 I got my Suburban I got all the
cars parked up since a regular day next
thing you know warning hail yep okay no
it's going to be fine it's going to be
Hill no not just hail I'm looking
outside the window golf size Shale
coming down I come outside the 750 BMW
looks like somebody did a drive-by with
like 50 Uzis
is this crazy then a guy knocks on the
door hey I think you need my help why
what do I need your help with your roof
is jacked up your car is messed up this
is what we do for a living we come to
places like you and you need you need
our help anyways eventually we end up
spending 148 000 on the roof okay to fix
it thank God we had insurance but we
still have to cough up forty thousand
dollars we have to spend money fixing
the car which was a mess and what
Dimitri does with this company directory
you get to go on there and try to find
any contractors you want in U.S and
Canada so imagine Uber for us and Canada
for contractors right here find the
perfect Pro for your home backed with
our twenty thousand dollar guarantee so
all contract directors are pre-screened
and vetted by multi-factor vetting
process that includes business
sustainability valuation safety or code
violation history background checks
Market references reviews online
presence and more whether it's Roofing
solar flooring Plumbing HVAC
or a multitude of other services
directory is the place where you can
find what you need for your home
improvement projects and with guarantee
it's going to be done right for you
again twenty thousand dollars the link
will be below download the app today and
start looking for the right contractor
for your need with a twenty thousand
dollar Peace of Mind guaranteed it's on
Apple Store and Google pay anyways it's
not just Roofing it's definitely not
Plumbing It's All Roofing solar
contractors and they do all the work for
you the best and this guy's a stud is
actually start on what he does so okay
there you go let's go back into the
story with uh uh musk and DeSantis hey
Rob do me a favor do a poll on the
podcast and ask the following question
do people prefer underground plumbing
I'm just joking do a poll and ask who
they believed one on Twitter spaces okay
was it musk was it Twitter was it the
santis or was it opposition just put
that and people folks vote I'm curious
to know what you think about well what
happens you're not Tom here's a question
for you some of the people on the other
side are talking about the mistakes
DeSantis made with Disney there's data
where we can look at to see if it's
favoring him or if it's hurting Disney
was this a good thing for the scientists
to go after Disney at a time like this
or is this something that Bob Iger is
doing because he needs it like you were
talking about off podcasts there's a
little bit of everything going on there
so if people were listening to this just
listen objectively to win uh DeSantis on
Twitter spaces said it's not fair that
Disney has their own way and doesn't pay
taxes while Sea World Universal and the
others are paying taxes as all the
wonderful tourists come to Florida to
enjoy themselves and go to these theme
parks he made that point and remember
you know Universal that's owned by
another media giant so the other media
giant saying damn straight I'm paying my
taxes ABC you know and Disney or not and
so there is an angle there that was very
true truthful that say hey I'm trying to
even the playing field up and they're
trying to make it sound like oh it's
because of woke things however Rob if
you can go find a Disney stock chart and
just go back six months just click on
Disney stock chart six months Bob Iger
rolled into town right after
Thanksgiving remember that was right
after Thanksgiving our hero is back it's
like a Disney movie you know here he is
and he immediately started laying off
people he announced that they were uh
changing some things that were going on
remember they raised parking rates and
stuff and he was trying to change some
of the pricing at the um at the theme
parks but Bob Iger has his hands full
and I believe this controversy is
helping Bob Iger move the dialogue
that's on his desk which is fixed Disney
so take a look here go back six months
right there you had a little pop-up
where you had this ramp that ran up to
February that's called the we're glad
our hero is back and the Disney goes
from 85 to 110. but now look since that
point on February 2nd Pat look at that
it's a trend line down it's gone up down
up down but it's heading down it's
because Bob Iger has not been able to
right away from 110 to 85. that's that's
not good yeah
if we can I I don't want to cut you off
if you go to Max
what I want to Disney's the first stock
I've ever owned in my life my
grandmother bought me stock when I was a
kid and I've had it forever if you go
back to I think this is pre-coveted I
want to say go back to the high point I
think it hit 180 at one point October of
2020 so even in during covet it was at
181 right maybe you could tell the full
breadth of the story of what actually
happened since covet where because his
woke agenda with with Bob Iger and
everything that's happening with the
Santas is a six-month story your story
but it's really a two three year story
of what's happening with Disney correct
but it's our hero coming back remember
jpeg was trying to stand behind the
scenes the former CEO he was behind the
scenes he was supporting a woke agenda
but he was not at war with DeSantis
there had been some words like hey buddy
you know we may need to talk about your
tax thing the war really started between
Iger and DeSantis and DeSantis is just
saying hey Disney you need to be just
like Universal just like Sea World just
like animal kingdom all the stuff you
need to pay your taxes and you had a
benefit it an economic benefit called
economic development that all cities do
to attract business and DeSantis is like
I think 50 years of Economic Development
benefits is enough and I'm going to take
it back and Iger is out there trying to
address profitability but now he's
talking about this because it's the
blame game he's got something to believe
he's got something to blame man it's not
my fault he did it it's Ron Ron did it
they did it if if it wasn't for Ron this
would have never happened to us that's
what Iger saying that's that's kind of
what Tom is saying great point which
Disneyland was closed and which was open
making Disney money
Florida
so chapek and Iger and the Disney
shareholders owe a little bit of a thank
you because there is millions of dollars
of ebitda that was created because
Disney was open and California was
closed is brilliant we all know Iger is
a genius we all know Iger is on the list
of top 10 top five Executives I'd say
top 10 Executives in the last no he's
probably top five top five Executives in
the last 40 years who do you put ahead
of them I only think about a couple
names and I'm talking I'm not talking
Founders because he's not a Founder I'm
talking executive so you can't put a
jobs or you know or some of these guys
exactly you got to put Welch as a 40.
you got a few names but I don't even
know if I put Welch ahead of him I think
Welch was for this guy to buy and
negotiate all the deals and get like
guys like jobs to
agreed to sell to what like no that's
not normal to do that
I think Bob Iger has to have a meeting
with his wife with his family with his
kids with his close friends with the
people he respects the most who will
give him sincere feedback if he hasn't
already had this meeting and guess what
Bob get in the ring
make a decision to get in the ring yes
get in the ring because oh it's too late
no it's not about this one here in the
next one here but start planning you
going into the ring you know it it
sounds like a guy that's itching to
fight these heavyweights but he's doing
it from the outside and it's a little
scared if you read his book uh
he talks about it that he was sitting
with Murdoch I believe who was he
sitting with Murdoch or one of those
guys Roger Ailes yeah and he was talking
about the fact that he has asked are you
going to run for president he's like I
told him no but I was thinking about
running for president why don't you just
make a decision and run and tell the
world about it look by the way he wrote
a book look how many views it's got look
how many reasons got wow 21 22 000
reviews right there I mean that's a
three-year-old book four-year-old book
that's doing that well so it's going to
be interesting to see what happens
because the scientist now has clearly
intentionally
picked his enemies and Disney is one of
them he's making it very clear one of my
enemies is Disney woke he's made it
clear Planned Parenthood abortion death
camp is one of his enemies six weeks
what he did you know he's going after
the education folks as also part of the
woke and uh indirectly you know he says
he said something on the live with
Twitter he says
he says let me tell you what I'm going
to do before I uh finish up with Florida
I'm gonna I'm gonna get everything done
till the last day I'm there so whatever
SOB comes after me has nothing to do
because everything's already been done
something like that I think he said SOB
or he said something a word like that
whoever comes after me doesn't have
anything to do okay they talk to him
about the Border by the way did you
watch him yesterday on Fox news with uh
Trey Gallery did you watch him last
night let's see how it did go to go to
Fox News let's see how it did to see how
people are reacting to
uh uh just go to YouTube yeah go to
YouTube and then go to trade go to uh
um Fox News look how sexy we look right
there well you make you looked everybody
go to videos videos Trey was leaning
back a little chill I thought he could
have been it was two parts keep going
down keep going keep going on top right
right here is that one no the what no
that's not the one keep going down
uh it was a part one and a part two with
Gowdy oh you're already at one day okay
there it is let's see what it did right
there
uh one day ago look how many views
that's not if you are not interested
yeah it's not good
that's not good you know why and look at
Gutfeld 331 views the same day 331 000
views on the same time yeah yeah and by
the way even Matt had 612 000 and even
Matt taibi got 256.
I mean he's got a marketing problem yeah
so so if you're on this dude sell the
dream
tell a story you're only selling the
nightmare
it's only you you don't say what we're
gonna do here's what's going on here's
what they're doing here's what are the
funerals I got that but tell me how
great America is tell me why this is the
greatest country in the world tell me
why my dream is going to become a
reality tell me what it's going to be
like when you're president if I'm gonna
walk down the aisle with my daughter
because she's going to marry somebody
because I have the money to pay for it
tell me what it's going to feel like
where I can go to my kids got college
graduation knowing my kid is now being
taught real history with what's going on
with none of this woke stuff and you're
going to be prouder University your kids
go to sell me the nightmare yes but also
sell me the dream you are not selling
the dream you know what it's like it's
like
is going to be a bad analogy but but
I'll give you the analogy
imagine if it was only foreplay
eventually I got a climax oh god of
course sell me to dream of what's to
come yeah let me tell you about 10
minutes you're gonna be shivering
you know like you're gonna be fired up
yeah don't leave okay sell me the dream
don't leave me with blue balls tell me
why this is the greatest country in the
world I want you to talk dirty to me
that's what I want okay because the guy
you're going up against he's talking
dirty to your girl and you got to do
that that's what he's doing you know who
the girl is in this situation America
America the voters yes I'm a Bank of
America yes
to be sold to dream and then you got to
come through with it good you sound like
you got excited
you sold me the dream pad I gotta I
gotta raise my flag right now in America
right brother well here's the thing I
don't think this is why he is going to
take your advice because if you just
listen to the words that come out of his
mouth this is what he said uh in his
Twitter spaces thing he said governing
is not entertainment
he said I'm not here to build a brand or
to Virtual signal build a brand Trump
virtual signal Biden all right he's like
indirectly calling people goes out he
says Merit must Trump identity politics
he didn't say Trump's name but he said
it in a different context uh he said we
must look forward not backward uh but
basically he's not here to be a marketer
his whole thing is that he's all about
competency over lunacy and whether
that's a winning message or not remains
to be seen I fully agree with you by the
way he needs to talk a little dirty you
know who's like that you know you know
which position in the White House works
if you have a position if you have a
position like that Chief of Staff Chief
of Staff exactly that's it a chief of
staff he you will be an incredible Chief
yeah but the first thing you know the
first thing I thought about here's what
the first thing I thought about I
thought about
um
I always forget this guy's name the
chief of staff that was there for
freaking God knows how many years Reagan
Bush everybody one of the most powerful
men the the book kind I read together
James Baker James Baker think about Jim
Baker this guy reminds me of a Jim Baker
because he's such a badass the scientist
is a flipping badass do not get a
twisted the guy is a BMF he is so
serious about the mission yeah so
serious that it's like always boom yeah
right that's the mindset of a soldier
Chief of Staff that's a mindset of a
general that's the mindset of a governor
he's governing but when you want to go
become a president to win 50 states you
kind of have to you don't have to win 56
but you don't know what I'm saying you
have to kind of market and tell the
story and talk dirty to the voter dog
you gotta like go you know he would have
been a great candidate great president
pre-social media we all know that it's
all about eyeballs no I think he'd even
predates that actually I'm going to
contradict myself and then I'm gonna go
straight to Tom let me contradict myself
in a go to Tom
what I'm saying to you right now
only matters in this election it may not
matter in 2028 but it matters because
he's going against Trump listen when
you're playing like for example like
what do coaches do before you're going
up against an enemy what do you do you
sit there and you call a place on how to
play defense on Michael on how to play
defense on Kobe or how to play defense
on LeBron you double team them you go
over here you go you got to make sure
the three-pointers we got to get them
here defense we're gonna play this and
step up don't give him space that guy
just so you know whenever he wants to
shoot a three let him he's a 29
percenter that guy's a 41 percent you
got to step up close to him don't give
him space he's always moving so we got
like you gotta have the strategy based
on your opponent your opponent is a run
and shoot offense your opponent is
Hollywood your opponent is a marketer
you gotta sell the dream now what I just
said to you he goes against the Biden
that's irrelevant it's irrelevant
against fighting yeah nobody cares like
the strategy changes immediately once it
goes against Biden fully agree yeah so
the only time it matters is your
opponent today
you were talking about his stories and
he's a veteran we're veterans how many
stories do you have in the military be
honest Pat from crazy to girl to
whatever he hasn't spend the rest of
podcasts
shout out to Felix militant like you got
the story I know he's done some crazy
stuff make yourself like I can't sell
some of them but what I'm saying let me
tell you the story
Patrick Patrick one of the greatest
pranks of all time yeah but you know
what I'm saying I want to see The Human
Side of this let me tell you one quick
story about my lieutenant kennel uh
peacocks all right yeah it's my number
one guy so him and I we used to go to
this club every weekend in uh Tennessee
we're talking about you're we're exactly
right what's on my practice right and we
were talking about
the way he said
we're not talking about practice
give me a team give me a player give me
what am I talking about he said it 14
times we're talking about practice yes
not a game post game
are you talking about it don't look
don't look that way post game interview
basketball put it away guys oh
basketball yeah you want to get it no AI
I'll give you initials AI
Allen Iverson was talking about uh Larry
Brown but it's okay go ahead Tom we're
talking about what you were talking
about is we're talking about DeSantis no
you're basically what we're talking
about is sales we're talking about sales
you have to sell that dream to the
people Ronald Reagan's sell point was
America is a shining City on a Hill
Obama's was about hope it's morning in
America these were the themes that great
presidential candidates were conveying
so that the average American could grab
hold of that and say I see what you
stand for and then when you're talking
about your policies that's the how but
there's got to be a dream with it
um John F Kennedy the F stands for
Fitzgerald his grandfather was John
Fitzgerald and they called him honey
fits and he was Legend in Boston you
know what he used to do Pat he used to
go pay a Coal Company to borrow a truck
full of coal and he would roll up his
shirt sleeves with the suspenders
driving around Boston waving to people
and they would say honey Fitz what are
you doing with the cold truck he says
I'm personally taking coal to the poor
because the people were freezing and he
drove it around all day now the punch
line is the truck was returned full to
the coal company at the end of the day
but he was driving around all day doing
what connecting connecting and he was
selling I'm taking coal to the poor and
so that angle of politics being able to
sell and sell the dream is as old as
door-to-door campaigning from the days
of Honey fits pre-television and so this
is nothing new you have to be deliver
something I mean when it absolutely
positively has to be there overnight
that's FedEx great campaigns great
marketing this is where DeSantis has to
go and showing yourself that hey you're
the smartest guy in the room and you're
the chief of staff is not the path to
the heart of the American voter yeah I
don't know man I I just feel like he's
got to win the vote he's got to sell the
dream he's got a woody audience he's got
a he's got to get up there playing like
Glennie Williams like you were here
girl you know I I I love you no matter
what you do and it's just playing and he
walks up
I hope you understand me he's gotta play
something smoke he's gotta play some
Jodeci Phoenix
oh he's got to play you know let's get
it on yeah he's got to play Let's Get It
On he's got he's gotta sell the dream
the dream Knocking the Boots that would
be that he would get the Houston vote
imagine if that happens
dude I'm telling you right now there's
something lacking in the marketing team
I'm telling you bro look how fast Biden
than them were like quick a team was
like yo put the link this link works
Boom the sentence I don't think has that
bro you know you know what's the great
quality of a great marketing person in
situations like this
um extremely sarcastic funny witty quick
yeah that's the key question you can
that skill set those things right there
yeah like you got to put a job posting
looking for people who are witty quick
funny sarcastic what yes come on quick
while you're watching you should say
this yeah you should say this let's post
this tweet this yeah retweet this make a
video doing this like for example let's
show Trump's video show Trump's videos
so good yeah I gotta give credit with
credit obviously Trump didn't come up
with this somebody on the team did but
again kudos to them marketing he'll take
credit I did it and then he was editing
all night and it was the one editing
again he did all the voices I sent him
one too I don't know if you saw the one
but I think it's a rocket on Twitter
yeah no this is what he's talking about
anyway so this is what Trump's response
to the Rhonda Sanchez's Twitter space
can you say who's on there you got Elon
Musk you got
[Music]
Hello is my microphone working correctly
George can you just wait while we no can
you hear me we can all hear you George
can you just hold on for a second
Twitter
oh can you hear me now can I please make
my big announcement now everyone just
hello
shut up George can somebody just mute
George
okay so how are we going to take out
Trump you guys uh
uh guys from the FBI this is not a
private call this is a public Twitter
space everyone can listen in
invited everyone to this uh this Twitter
space so Governor Ron DeSantis could
everyone just shut the hell up so I can
make my announcement okay you go girl
wait the devil is gay so what everyone
in this call is gay
guys
can we please just calm down
so anyway guys I just wanted to announce
that I'm okay I can hear the governor
very very shut up would you please shut
up already I'm running for [__]
president okay
congratulations Governor
uh well that concludes our Twitter space
for today thank you to all of our hold
your horses Elon the real president is
going to say a few words the devil I'm
gonna kick your ass very soon Hitler
you're already dead and Dick Cheney
sounds like you'll be joining Hitler
very soon Klaus Schwab and George Soros
I'm putting both your asses in jail and
run the sanctimonious can kiss my big
beautiful 2024 presidential ass Trump
2024 baby let's go first of all go to
the likes go to the likes let's see how
many views I got just click on likes and
click on it yes let's see I'm ah [__]
It's not going to show it I'm curious
this thing out I know by the way 200.
that was hilarious yeah oh Patrick are
you kidding me no shout out to Trump's
Market what did I send you what was that
video that I sent you that was the pat
do you see the one that the Trump and I
approved this message it got 7.2 million
views by the way the live the Twitter
spaces got five million views the
Twitter spaces this thing got 7.2
million views sometimes less is more I'm
just glad he left me out of it yeah oh
my God see that's the part though now
somebody may say well that's not uh you
know is that kind of what we want that's
not what we want in America it's not
your choice that's your opponent you
don't get to choose your opponent your
opponent is a guy named Donald J Trump
who's a master troll or Master Market or
Master sarcasm witty quick sharp all of
that that's your opponent you cannot
complain about whether that's how it
should be or that's presidential or not
he happens to be a former president who
believes can do it again and you got to
get better strategies to go up against
the guy random question pack because I
know with Biden and Harris they were on
the debate stage and she called him a
racist she was like you're this you're
this you're that if Twitter space has
got 9 million
uh I saw five million when Sac City got
five million views if it's at 9 million
now it's at nine I don't know the exact
number but a short clip like that got
seven and a half million a short list a
short club like that got seven and a
half million go ahead so so um in
regards to so so it's gonna be obviously
it's actually 3.8 million people tuned
in so it's really 3.8 million I was
actually a little higher oh go ahead not
bad I'm gonna do one more time
I love you uh so Pat Uh uh debate stage
Adam it was uh I read that was on the
stage and it got down the hill uh
Hillary Kamala this is Biden this is 20
20. yeah and it was he was going after
her she was going after him called him a
racist and all that it's over fighting
wins and what happens she's the VP is
there any chance no it's just hold on
I'm not even let you ask the question
let me ask the question if this is not
going to be Trump's VP go ahead and ask
let me ask yourself people are just
jumping in there go ahead trumpet the
sentence kind of go out of there dude
they run the second morning but hear me
out though for the party does Trump does
this does Trump tell the dancers like
listen it's over we shake I won but
listen to me you stay with me for four
years you're gonna get the next eight
that ship has sailed at 100 the ship has
sailed it's gone what do you like after
you go down zero chance zero I don't
think it's zero but I think this is a
lot different than a group of people
that are going after each other on
policy maybe getting a little personal
and then they all gather together to
sweep up the votes at the National
Convention
that's the normal way it works but I'm
with Adam I think in this case this ship
is sale plus both of them are not
favorable among women women do not like
Trump for the entire Grabber by the you
know adultery I'm not going to say no
thank you and then Ron DeSantis with his
abortions I think both of them need a
female to be their vice president
great point if you have to pick a vice
president for Trump or DeSantis who
cares I think Trump goes Kerry Lake I
think the santis goes Nikki Haley I
agree 100 if they won today today I
agree with that you got to think about
Tulsi guys
I love Tulsi she was awesome I thought
that that was great by the way on a
serious note we we you know pbd believes
in analytics uh believes in business
analysts in this thing you've heard him
talk about that we pulled real numbers
this is not a joke can we pop that up
Pat absolutely Tom this is great so we
have the volutainment polling analytics
and you're going to see that because
we're gonna pull stuff together and and
try to make sense of it this is real
data there's no jokes here so let's
start with Iowa in the valutainment too
damn early poll we we took a look at the
last three
um reputable pollsters now they're not
always right but these are National
pollsters some lean left suddenly right
but they're real pulling grips signal
and did it at the beginning of April
American greatness right at the second
week of May and then right after the
Trump Town Hall uh a a three-day poll
was run by Emerson this is a very
reputable group again they lean left not
always right but they're reputable take
a look at this Trump went from plus
seven on the signal poll to 18 American
greatness poll to plus 42. look what
happened there and you look how Pence
can you explain it for people to see it
so if I'm looking at it look at Emerson
and go right across look at the dates
right 519 through 522 shows Trump 62
DeSantis 20 pence five Haley five
ramswani two and it says Trump is now up
42. so I'm going across while Tom is
explaining this go ahead yep and then
you go to American greatness that poll
was taken two weeks you know about that
week and a half prior about a week and a
half prior Trump was at 44 according to
American greatness the sanus was 26 and
Pence was four and Haley was six or Emma
Swani so he and so Trump was up 18 on
second place to sanus and then the
signal poll that was at the beginning of
April remember beginning of April
there's a lot of media running around
but neither Trump or DeSantis had done
anything really huge and so Trump was
plus seven so there was a big pop now
that's Iowa which is a blue State and
the red part of Iowa is very dedicated
and remember that's Trump land that's
Middle America now let's scroll down and
look at New Hampshire in the too damn
early poll the New Tampa New Hampshire
two damn early poll
the saint anslem ran it right at the end
of March Trump was 42 to Santa's 29
Trump was 13. then the University of New
Hampshire that's UNH right in the middle
of April April 13th to 14th they ran the
poll Trump was 42 DeSantis was 22 so
Trump by 20. and then American greatness
ran a poll right in the middle of May
but right after the clear American
greatness has nothing to do with mega
make America great again it just happens
to have the same word correct they're
just these are just thank you very much
that's right just the that's just the
name of the polling group and Trump was
39 to Santa's 18. now in New Hampshire
there's the son of the former Governor
Chris sununu former governor and also
prominent in the bush White House Bush
senior White House John sununu so sununu
has got home court advantage up there
but look sununu in the recent poll was
basically tied with the 17-18 and
Trump's 21 up on everybody and so it's a
little bit early but this is showing
Trump got a real bump and then we pulled
the by the way if you look at if you go
back up to that real quick look at
Rama's one he doubled yeah yeah you can
look at his moment you know they shut
him down on LinkedIn and then he came
back up with the LinkedIn he said
something uh oil or he's coming he's he
made a comment about fossil fuel and
Linkedin on the green side got all
pissed off and shut him off oh God and
uh let's look at just a real quick
National look now remember the primaries
is what matters so the reason we're
looking at States Tom get up there and
do your dance yeah
you can see here Trump is the purple
line at the top and the vertical line
there is May 11th that is the CNN Town
Hall
Trump gotta pop up after the CNN Town
Hall see there to to highest ever and
then you see he drops down a bit that
was seven days ago when desanta said I'm
officially running and I'm going to make
my announcement and then to Santa's got
a little bit of air in the room but look
at everybody at the bottom just kind of
bang around at the bottom Pence Haley
and everybody this is a two-horse race
but look at the trend line the trend
line doesn't look good for DeSantis
right now on a national basis now we've
just he does have a bump back up though
if you look at it it's like bump back up
and Trump's gotta bump down since
Twitter spaces if you look at it right
and so we've got 60 days so ladies and
gentlemen value team at polling
analytics we're gonna be diving into
this stuff in a little over 60 days from
now actually closer to 90. we're going
to be in August and Milwaukee and then
the Reagan Museum they're within 10 days
of each other in August the Republican
debates let's see if everybody shows up
because that's we're going to see all
these folks on stage going at it
by the way this is a very if you're
watching this gang if you like a Tom
doing a segment on this uh on the
podcast do you let us know if you like
this segment or not for Tom to go
through something to say this is very
helpful for me to look at to see uh uh
the polls okay so here's here's the
another thing that I kind of want to uh
talk about that has nothing to do with
the election but it does two things
happened okay one targets stock is down
12 they lost 9 billion dollars in a week
due to trying to Pander to this ESG
score you know lgbtq they lost nine
billion dollars in a week Anheuser-Busch
Bud Light is down Bud Light is down 25
in sales if you look at their numbers
and there's a couple things if you go to
Twitter I posted this yesterday and
shared a clip of Larry Fink from
BlackRock because a lot of people even
yesterday when I was with Andrew Schultz
on their podcast flagrant shout out to
those guys what a freaking great crew of
people from the beginning to the end of
Music great Vibe no not this one go to
the next one the one where he talks
about no stay on there go back there but
just go to my account and go back to the
Tweet right before right there yeah
click on that that's where he talks
about force and zoom in a little bit
zoom in a little bit yeah that one zoom
in a little bit okay Target loses 9
billion dollars in a week after
introducing lgbtq friendly kids clothing
stock is down 25 Bud Light down 25
percent lessons from all Fortune 500
lessons to all Fortune 500 CEOs and CMOS
number one screw your ESG score instead
focus on keeping your best customers
happy these guys don't realize who their
best customers are number two you can't
please both the ESG community and your
best customers at the same time
attempting to do so will cost you both
you saw what happened right now with the
ESG and the CEI score coming back and
saying we're disappointed in the way
Anheuser-Busch handled them so they went
from having a perfect score of 100 boom
they no longer do three it's time for
the board to fire the Sea on the entire
marketing team not doing so will
continue this downfall here's what the
targets see O'Brien Cornell said after
the backlash defending the lgbtq
friendly merchandise was the right thing
for society double dumb number four bad
ideas have consequences and number five
capitalism Works pandering doesn't
either go into politics and sell your
woke policies to voters or be a true
capitalist in capitalism your best
customers are your voters not the point
one percent of Voters who complain and
scream the loudest so this
goes to the next tweet with the video of
uh Larry Fink from BlackRock very
casually the way he says it he just says
it in such a way it's as if it's like
yeah it's not a big deal you know Zoom
that out a little bit before you play
the video on what I'm saying Force
equals ESG equals BlackRock can you zoom
in the Tweet yeah that right there four
sequels yes equals BlackRock force is a
bad strategy for those who prefer
Freedom Force works for the majority
give most exact some money give them
some recognition it works but Force
doesn't work on Independent thinkers and
doers listen to the word he uses here go
ahead
now behaviors are going to have to
change this is one thing we're going to
we're asking companies
you have to force behaviors and at
BlackRock we are forcing behaviors well
behaviors
and by the way he's saying this you know
how much assets they have on their
management as of December 31st of 2022
10 trillion honors 10 trillion trillion
10 trillion though
Ken he was a CEO okay 10 trillion
dollars 70 offices in 30 countries and
clients in 100 countries
some of these countries that don't like
America but these guys are more
representing the globalist brand because
they have such wide reach of what they
can do and one of the ways they can make
their clients happy is through ESG to
control the behavior of what theater
companies do so force force is the key
word so guess what
if if I'm running a campaign you know
what I'd be selling here's what I'd be
selling a phone descent he can give this
message I would say listen in America
your vote is really two votes
you're either part of the force
Community you're part of the freedom
Community the force Community is forcing
you to do XYZ the freedom Community is
foreign the force Community is doing
this it's Force versus Freedom America
wants to be free Don't Force certain
agenda to my kids in school where we
don't want our kids to learn this stuff
that is force we don't want you to do
that
Americans by choice by DNA are Freedom
Fighters The Establishment their
favorite word is force
and very rarely do you hear them use it
that publicly in this instance he used
it very comfortably yeah and Pat in
regards not not to ship but you were
since we're on the target situation
first of all shout out to all the
Americans that are going against all
this [__] all this push dude think about
it they lost not over nine billion
dollars in seven days of their of their
company that's freaking amazing shout
out to all the Americans that are
sticking up for that [__] the Budweiser
thing I could care less North Faces did
something with some outside drag queen
they're getting backlash Pat I just sent
this clip to uh Rob on Instagram David
Harris Jr pointed it out on Instagram
guys inside of Target Pat holding that
he's like hey to one of the employees
he's like hey what's uh what's going on
with demon stuff and you know what the
employee says she's like I don't believe
in God I believe in Satan and I don't I
don't think it's can you show that Pat
this is on this this is an actual Target
employee these are people that work at
Target look at this
um
what's God gonna think of that I don't
believe in god wow
so you think do you need help with
something you support the propaganda
that's targeting the kids
targeting kids all it's all of our kids
TV shows
it's all over they're targeting the kids
choose to wear whatever they want
support the sexualization of kids
through Pride propaganda by corporate is
there something
what about you sir do you support this
any questions but if you're here to
cause any disturbance I'm just asking
questions
I am the undercover
anymore so
I'm just asking questions so do you
support this satanic propaganda I'm not
sure there's questions
what you need to do is you either need
to leave the store
what do you think the problem is in
general just it's and I've said this
before there is a blatant attack on the
youth and the kids we care the American
public a majority of us do but it's like
these people like you said are forcing
the [__] on us kid they have no chance
at him from Tick Tock brainwashing them
as children from in the schools to this
woke gender chop off it's okay and like
it's it's an attack and it's like bro
I'm happy that we're standing up but
it's they're not even hiding bro they're
they're not even hiding anymore evil is
in plain sight and I mean we have to
like nip that [__] in the blood right
now because it's getting out of control
but all these people work they not only
push it they have employees that are
like this I hear you uh one thousand
percent on a corporate level yeah this
lady's making twelve dollars an hour I
don't care what her ideology is she's
she's just she's lucky she has a job at
this point you know the guy coming in he
has a point I get it yeah but the whole
holier than thou God will judge you it's
like dude I'm working at [__] Target
making twelve dollars an hour I don't
need to be on camera no no answering
your questions no bill my thing is I'm
with you yeah mine is deep like let's
not make her the poster no no she's not
supposed to tell what I'm saying mine is
going deeper it's like bro if the
company itself Target and all these
companies are going in a meeting Pat
nothing gets posted on valuetainment
unless Mario everybody goes okay we're
good post it for Target to say okay this
designer demon Satan loves pronouns gay
tucking underwear for children that's
one thing that's the point even if
they're hiring people that are like that
come on bro well it's like when is it
going to stop you can't you can't hire
people based on ideology well well dude
ideology aside it's like bro we have to
protect the kids and it's getting out of
control and that's why people are losing
it's almost 10 billion dollars in seven
days I agree so my point was I'm just
proud yes yeah Americans are stepping up
and I hope I'm not dude I was gonna go
to Target yesterday to go shopping I
turned around I'm not going there I'm
like we're gonna go to Target to buy
some Bud Light what are we going to buy
damn Walmart until they mess up going to
Walmart buy some Coors Light yeah but
anyways I didn't want to get off that
but it's like these people when are they
gonna get it Bud Light nobody learned
their lesson Target they're not learning
a lesson North Face is doing it right
now they're starting to lose money it's
like when are people gonna wake up you
know guy a girl yesterday responded back
to uh the tweet I posted about ESG if
you can't go to it and and let's see her
name if you can go I'd like to give her
credit if you can go back up to the
tweet I had Rob not that one the other
one prior to that yeah if you can go
there please uh I want to say your name
is Gina or G okay there it is zoom in uh
yeah she said uh they will uh they will
all fall in line regardless of what
public wants unfortunately it's the
queering of corporate America okay so
let's unpack that they will all fall in
line regardless of what the public wants
unfortunately is the queering of the
corporate America great you know what
that tells me that's a helpless weak
statement that we can't do anything
about that's a statement that you don't
believe in the power of we the people
and you don't believe strong men and
women who are True Believers exist now I
don't know who she is I'm sure she's got
good intentions
but if you see the response below here's
the part this isn't anything new weak
men have existed since day one they've
ruined many empires however they've also
woken up True Believers with backbones
who won't cave True Believers are waking
up they're bringing hope they True
Believers can you click on show more Rob
please uh True Believers with
strong values and convictions scared the
crap out of the establishment future
looks bright I have a feeling you know
this is going to be an Awakening of uh
uh one of my favorite quotes of all time
is sometimes God puts a Goliath in your
life to bring out the David in you I
think it's going to be a lot of David's
waking up right now at a time like this
it's it's so interesting when all of a
sudden you well you had no desire to get
in a fight has nothing to do with you
and then they cross the line with kids
and all of a sudden you're like I'm
sorry man my blood is boiling right now
I'm not happy about what you're doing
with kids you're not going to do that to
my kids to my nephew to my niece to this
to that I I'm stepping up and I'm going
to do something about it I think that's
kind of what's going on right now and by
the way it's all concept with this ESG
argument
um it's great that the people
are reacting the way they are to Target
and to you know Bud Light there's a
difference between canceling and moving
your vote
historically we change presidents we go
left we go right we go left we go right
we go left we go right we go Reagan Bush
Clinton
Bush Obama Trump Biden we just do this
because we're like well I need a better
option I think they can do it better you
know you know what I miss that guy you
know what I miss Trump you know what I
miss Obama you know what I miss Bush you
know what they just kind of go back and
forth this is what they do okay
so same thing goes with uh uh what do
you call it buying a drink you go to a
restaurant they don't handle they don't
take care of you you leave you go to a
different place right
that's a great thing about capitalism
why it's so hard in capitalism
your voters are going to leave you
if you don't respect them
you know voters are very loyal they're
honest they'll come back and eat at the
same place if I told you right now what
businesses have you gone back and bought
from a hundred plus times you would
probably come up with a list of names
you've gone to Uber hundreds of times
you've got to liver a place that sends
you to liver all the time all the time
we go to places hundreds of times we are
valuable customers to certain businesses
this ESG thing what it does is it spits
in the face of loyal customers and a
loyal customer is eventually going to
sit there and say the following I'll
give you a Perfect Analogy here
you know we had a guy I was working with
at the former company he comes in
insurance
and he had a boss former boss that when
it came down to promotion he didn't give
it to him
and he says I'm not going to give it to
you I'm going to give to somebody else
anyways the guy doesn't get the
promotion and he leaves
he come starts working with us gets
excited good things are happening he's
very happy everything good is happening
to him right all of a sudden
the former boss is now going through
issues he realizes he valued that guy a
lot he calls him back and he offers him
a ridiculous comp to go back to the
company
then that guy comes up and says hey man
I got to tell you I got this opportunity
go back and my boss is giving me this I
said I'm sorry I remember you telling me
about what your former boss did to you
yeah okay and you're gonna go back to
the guy that did this yeah
then that means you don't value your
loyalty
you value money
and if you value money you're going to
get destroyed you may win short term you
may be a nice salary short term but long
term you're gonna get destroyed because
the moment of value of loyalty isn't
High to you
the Market's also going to treat you as
loyalty isn't important to them right
now Fortune 500 companies who are trying
to increase their ESG scores what
they're saying to the customers is hey
customer screw you we don't value you
above our ESG Score first comes
BlackRock and all the money people then
comes you when your priority flips like
that people leave
it happens in relationships it happens
in small businesses it happens in
friendships it happens in Brotherhood it
happens in siblinghood it happens
everywhere and it's happening to these
guys and I love this is why I love
capitalism because it's so freaking
honest straight up if you forget the
basic rule of your customers you're
going to get screwed and that's exactly
what's happening to these guys that's
all I can say about ESG so keep doing it
keep pandering keep trying to please
both guys you know who you're going to
lose both of them then you're going to
be there by yourself oh I was hoping to
get the girl and my best friend life
doesn't work that way bro you went and
hooked up with your best friend's girl
you're you're a scumbag is what you are
you know where you belong nowhere
whoever you date next is going to know
that you're gonna do it to them again
and whoever is your friend next is going
to know you're going to do them to do
that to them again people spread and
they talk about who you are they DM each
other so who you know who that guys do
you know who's really there do you know
who's this Everybody Talks except in the
ESG space
it's public
it's so awesome Gotta Love capitalism
such a great system ain't it don't you
just love capitalism yes I do sir and I
love America isn't that awesome Tom
it's pure yeah it's pure it's on it's
it's straight up and if you screw with
it it'll ruin your life well to the um
to the entire Port you're making the
beginning if you pull up that tweet that
Pat was responding to to kind of circle
back to what wrong if she's single or
something like that yeah can you zoom in
Adam's more interested to see I know a
lot of the guys in the comments think
I'm gay for some whatever [__] reason
but okay oh my God who's that yeah yeah
hit me up go back to her tweet though I
love her
um the bat was basically talking about
you she's gorgeous but basically
you're talking about essentially the
decline of America and via the corporate
queering of America right here I
actually really appreciate what the
Sanders had to say
um
me being pro-america yeah uh he said
American decline is not inevitable okay
it is a choice and it what I hope to
bring is the revitalation revitalization
of America and not a president who takes
cues from the woke mob and it's the
inmates running the Asylum and that's
essentially what is going on right here
uh to kind of tie in what DeSantis is
saying with the ESG back to that a
couple quick points he basically came
out and he said as I'm anti-esg what do
you do in Florida basically uh mandated
that no ESG in any of the uh retirement
funding accounts anything that's
happening here in Florida that might be
a federal thing nationally he says no
social credit scores and no
um
Central Bank digital currencies he came
out and he made those statements and he
said I Am pro Bitcoin which I think was
interesting because he's going after the
sort of libertarian free thinker vote
um whereas Biden he says quote unquote
would kill it meaning kill Bitcoin so
Florida you were just you were just at
an event
and mayor Suarez also says he's running
for president apparently with spring
talking about that
um not exact Whispers he's been a
proponent trying to bring Bitcoin to
Florida so oh yeah there's a unified
voice there about Florida supporting
Bitcoin
Bitcoin not [__] coin yep
just did this the moment of silence
where somebody has to say uh let's go
into a prayer real quick
Heavenly Father we'd like to pray for
Dylan Mulvaney we'd like to pray for
Vinnie Mulvaney we'd like to do a quick
uh Pat Loki constantly thinking about
Dylan Mulvaney because his son is Dylan
one of his sons who's like the best
no to even put that thought in my head
you're the one that brought it up the
first time
because your son is such a freaking stud
yeah it's like offensive to the name
yeah it's Emily it's a great name it's
it's I actually like his name it's a
it's a first and last name yeah and and
I think what he's doing is he's doing
what he's doing the the world is giving
him attention and he's taking it it is
what it is but okay so so let's finish
this up let's finish this up here and uh
uh go back to our uh business here folks
if you're listening Tom Vinnie Adam you
guys as well
how early is it for people to pick
winners meaning
you know the saying wow you know the the
never in the history the NBA has a team
come back from being three upons
tomorrow
if the Celtics win tomorrow in Miami
it's games dude you're gonna go back to
Celtics
winning games six it's over so here's
the point I'm making to you is
is is is the scientist Jimmy Butler or
is the santis Tatum is this going to be
a situation where Miami is up three
nothing Celtics come back Trump is up
three nothing right now with the big ass
lead what is the likelihood that the
santis without a blunder from the other
side meaning if Trump gets indicted if
Trump they're going to take them down
and he can't compete which any of those
things can happen as well but say that
doesn't happen what is the likelihood of
DeSantis beating Trump in the primary
give me a percentage
it all depends oh my God
you want a story okay I'm gonna give you
a question at this point I've been
hearing so many facts I like a couple
stories you know Trump is actually gonna
get on the debate stage he will of
course you think he will that's the
biggest X Factor you don't think that
guy wants to talk guys that's like Saint
John Jones doesn't want to fight yeah
well he was doing cocaine he couldn't
fight for a little while John he loves
to fight you know you I hear you but
it's not like I just came up with the
story out of [__] nowhere yeah
there's been chatter about Trump not
being on the debate stage so the point
is let's assume he's going to be on the
debate stage yeah
um who's gonna be on the debate stage
you got to Santas you got Pence yeah you
might have Mike Pompeo yeah you have
sununu you got Nikki Haley you got
Scotty Swami so let's see how he takes
that barrage of attack versus dishing it
out so I think it's gonna be made for
TV Prime Time way better than it was in
16 and 20. okay because now there's
people his VP is talking [__] to him
what's the problem so what the
percentage is they making a comeback
winning the primary yeah 30 percent
he's not Donald Trump is on in Revenge
mode and he's saying hold on let me film
something sorry he's in Revenge mode
just from the Durham report by itself
bro Obama Biden Hillary the FBI
everybody colluded to get his ass out
and for all those years he is furious he
wants revenge and he deserves it bro he
deserves it that's what I'm that's it I
think he has a 30 chance unless he does
some outlandish [__] Trump is looking
for fire Rob said this yesterday it's
Don versus Ron 2024. Donald Trump is
gonna he's gonna win bro hear me out
whoever those side people are Rama Swan
you all them Adam it's like who's gonna
team up on who the most you know what I
mean are they gonna all go after Trump
Moore or the Santa smart things going to
be Trump or do Trump Trump's a legend
and I think he's gonna win he's out for
blood period uh I'm kind of a student of
political history and I went back and I
looked and I saw there was a time when
Mike Huckabee for almost two months was
it's a done deal Mike Huckabee is going
to be the nominee it's a done deal Scott
Walker Wisconsin remember that uh yeah
not as long as Huckabee but yeah you're
correct there's been there's moments
where wow Scott Walker this can be the
guy this is done it's a done deal it's
gonna happen or Jeb Bush never
um and then I'll show you a time where
there was three weeks where Condoleezza
Rice LED all uh candidates so they're in
the traditional elections there tends to
be time where
these things pop up like this and for
Huckabee for Walker for Conde and you
think wow there's our candidate it's
it's over this time and I love saying
this because this is what Silicon Valley
says about the economy all the time and
about new companies right Pat this time
it's different but I do believe this
time it's different I'm I'm at DeSantis
has a 33 chance of getting the
nomination that's where I'm at good good
number Tom and the reason I think that
is it's not impossible but there are so
many things we've already talked about
today I won't listen to them that he
really needs to learn and being a astute
political intellect about the things
that America needs on policy he's got
that covered but that's not what the
people that are out there hurting from
inflation hurting from things they want
and Trump is that guy and Trump has got
the evidence behind him he's like listen
I'm not this bombastic guy look at what
I did and look at what I did with China
was I right I mean the um the thing that
Trump can run on a simple campaign
slogan a dream for America but also was
I right
you could say I said I had nothing to do
with Russia was I right I said that
China was dangerous I should push him
economically was I right I said that the
southern border needed a lot of help and
I didn't get the full wall built because
they blocked me was I right and so
that's pretty powerful now what he can't
walk away from is this very
very you know the offensive side where
you have key parts of the of the voting
blocks that um that like like women
educated women are like ah gosh they
just they just can't get around that but
I think right now it's 33 for uh
DeSantis intellect aside I don't think
he can become the politician he needs to
be to win the mob well you know I'm a
Vegas guy I always I say I don't trust
Pew I don't trust Quinnipiac and all
this stuff so I just quickly
I said because they got skin in the game
and take a guess who is the current
favorite from Vegas take a guess my
favorite of all everyone everyone for be
president okay you're going what do you
think I think Vegas is probably gonna
Biden but a little bit more okay then
who's number two Trump trump okay and
then who's number three Ron okay by the
way you said 33 you said 30. 30 said 33
uh roll the dice right here buddy uh Joe
Biden is the favorite uh six to four
odds so what is that 66 percent give or
take yeah uh Donald Trump twelve to five
odds which is about 40 percent 12
divided by five
twenty five percent that's where it is
and then it falls off a cliff then you
got RFK Kamala Michelle Gavin Nikki so
it's a three-legged race three horse
race Joe Biden at the top right now
that'll obviously change once there's a
clear Republican nominee right uh Trump
and DeSantis 25 that's where Vegas puts
him right now Tucker and Pence tied at
50-1 Tim Scott Hillary Clinton's even on
there that's actually not a bad Buy
that's actually not a bad buy Believe it
or what Hillary Clinton at age one no I
you know why that's not a bad buy
because she never underestimate a
ambitious lazy person who is willing to
do anything and everything it takes to
get to the top she is the ultimate lazy
ambitious person that wants to be a
president and very deceptive very strong
uh she can move a lot of different
things for that to happen go a little
bit higher look at Michelle Obama ahead
of Newsome but ahead of Nick Haley yeah
yeah because there's an open field on
the left so much on the right one
observation Pat look at how many
Republicans from vivec to all these
people that that the the right has the
left has no who is his left half Robert
Kennedy okay I get it but then comma
they have nobody not about candidates
that's what I'm saying is I'm saying
look at the pool where's the people the
right has the left is just barely
hanging bro gang
that's a for sure miss but even if you
think about it okay they have Biden who
else do they really have besides Kennedy
they don't like the Republicans six to
four in the face of unsorted confusion
it's less confused those that's the
worst bet to make
to say Biden's good like that Joe
manchin 101. let me let me explain
something dude Joel if okay if the
people that voted for Biden because they
just wanted to get Trump out if you
still vote for Biden with the [__]
that's been happening you are an idiot
okay and the only way he's gonna win is
if God forbid this new pandemic that the
who just said is coming out that all
these people are warning us about fauci
everybody and you have to stay home and
vote there is no way in in if you if he
wins something is off something is wrong
don't even how can you clearly vote for
somebody after what the hell we've been
seeing for these three years you lived
in California for 10 years I think you
know what they've no no no what are you
talking about what I'm saying is it was
Trump and covet and okay finally the the
orange bad crazy man he's gone now we
got Joe Biden
abysmal presidency so far what I'm
saying is the fact that he's number one
if he wins the the entire presidency
something is wrong Joe Biden is the goat
upside down though Joe Biden is the gold
from the other way yeah yeah if he's
just gonna they're gonna trust me bro
they're gonna keep him in the White
House how do you
explain to me how he can win who how can
you vote for Joe Biden right now in your
right mind EX tell me that if somebody
says infrastructure I'm gonna walk out
of that I'm not I'm not trying to sell
you this but I I guarantee you
without a doubt
49 to 50 percent of the country will
vote for him that's banana what do you
mean they already did it no but yeah
what I'm saying because they'll do it
again because that's insane I don't want
you to I don't want your brains to end
up all over I don't want it to blow it's
going to happen it's just expect it it's
going to be a close election then 50 of
the people are stupid and you're stupid
before he loses his mind fully let's
take a break here and I'm talking like a
three-day break yeah uh what do we got
going on here we got so Tuesday we'll be
back with home team podcast and then on
Thursday we have two of the three FBI
whistleblowers who testified in front of
Congress last week oh two of the three
two of the three the third's not doing
any media now but the other two will be
joining us uh Garrett O'Boyle and Steve
friend interesting and then Friday next
Friday one week from today fresh and fit
live event here at valuetainment Studios
fantastic June 2nd 5990 live.com put
that link up 59.90 live event.com just
America in General on this Memorial Day
weekend God rests The Souls of all the
soldiers that fought for us to give us
this freedom I want everybody to just by
yourself ask yourself one simple
question uh are you better off than you
were four years ago four years ago so
let me just crack that in there oh that
sound and guess what go ahead Thomas
what do you have to say it says if
you're not better off than you were four
beers ago maybe go Memorial Day week let
me get a beer and chill a little bit and
remember you've got a whole year until
you have to vote God bless you all
America we're the [__] my man take care
everybody have a great weekend bye bye
that's fine